uh when yo when mo3 was alive you guys
didn't get along much right or am I
wrong about that you're wrong I'm wrong
you guys did get along we never had no
problem you never had no problem okay
because I okay I was gonna ask you like
mo3's passing it feels like nationally
he finally got
the love that like he deserved when he
was alive but it took him dying for
people to come to his [ __ ] and really
like dive into his [ __ ] like how big of
a loss was mo3 uh to the city of Dallas
it was a big it was that was a big ass
impact for him like on the whole city
like
and then the [ __ ] like the song which
shout out to LG Bible business you know
that's the reason that's his song and
[ __ ] but he's from Dallas as well of
course of course yeah and that's uh
that's another [ __ ] that's going crazy
he's a super nice guy yeah cool
[ __ ] yeah so that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] that's like that's one up for
them boys bro like real talk but it made
an impact in the city for sure yeah do
you feel like it kind of like it sucks
because I even feel like obviously
Nipsey was was bigger than mo3 when he
was alive but like I feel like the
impact of nipsey's Music wasn't really
felt and or appreciated yeah right it
felt similar it was like damn now people
like are really [ __ ] with Nipsey that
weren't even listening to his [ __ ] when
he was alive you know what I mean it
sucks that like sometimes you gotta see
somebody past to really get the love and
respect that they deserve in this rap
[ __ ] for sure that's how that [ __ ] go
bro yeah a lot of people don't get
appreciated it just it always got to be
some type of [ __ ] for a lot of
people to get their flowers though you
know what I'm saying sometimes so you
just always just I guess it's part of
the game